yes going to welcome them to this video
Thomas tell us is the opponent he takes
a few seconds to answer the eloquent
seven as it often happens it is not an
opening there people study all that much
you went with g3 it's not bad of course
they're both recaptures make some sense
but why not this yeah where'd you go
sometimes the night is not that great on
v6 actually so Knight f6 could could
make some sense I mean it looks like 90
at 65 and back but I mean white has
played a 45 takes and that didn't really
help white or all that much either
anyway um
this is certainly very solid for white
but will not he'll put big pressure on
the black player interesting I don't I'm
not sure that this makes sense ready to
be honest I mean you can certainly play
b3 but is it ready
is it really all that helpful after
Bishop f6 you have to trade and weaken
the dark squares oh yeah 193 which you
also don't want to play really mean it's
not terrible but
yeah yeah I was thinking like D 5 C 6 a
blunt blunt everything
the bishop only towards looking at a
pawn or now
yeah rupee 8 now makes some sense
prevent Night Moves I mean the DEP that
looks a little bit unnatural voice okay
d 4 d 4 and then okay fish 94 so this
looks very natural
now D for threatening to be material
ready not default light moves it hangs
so it's a bit now what am I missing here
do you for I don't know I really don't
know
quite resilient sure yeah the archives
struck again somehow yeah it makes
people play weird stuff sometimes yeah
not much to look at a g3 is actually not
a bad line I mean this is something that
I have recommended to people wanted
something very very very basic and
simple fist against this opening and
going you you get your pieces out and
it's okay but you should you should
certainly proud prioritize on kingside
development now I just wonder a night if
three years as this which is a bit
annoying yeah and it's not great anyway
I wonder I really thought that this
could be something for white at some
point straight by wasn't tireless a
couple of times but how did wasn't our
display it probably be four or something
I mean white cannot be worth him but
with this b3 business it starts to be a
little bit you should probably take now
on f6 and here this is a this is quite
convenient rally so Quincy won and now
he has to do something about defy simply
didn't do much about it now a simple
thread is d4 and he has to stop it at d3
for example as the engine suggests I
mean black is certainly comfortable here
what Bishop especially doesn't make more
sense okay it's it's probably equal or
something like that but this is just
giving me a piece now here just didn't
have a good good game there yeah okay
guys thanks for watching